ich habe mir einen 200 quadratmeter büro
angemietet um es genau nach meinen
vorstellungen umzubauen nachdem wir
bereits gelernt haben selber wende zu
ziehen das auch getan haben und uns
einen traum streamen raum gebaut haben
wird es heute zeit für die ersten möbel
und das gestalten der wendezeit gespannt
und bleibt jetzt dran geschichte seit
gespannt und bleibt jetzt daran für eine
neue folge
eine woche urlaub wir sind zurück back
to business im neuen büro heute startet
die entscheidende woche sowie ist wieder
da max ist da wo sie unglaublich scheiße
aus werden in stream kaufen im letzten
video fertig gemacht hier noch ein
kurzer ausschnitt
und diese woche geht es endlich an die
gestaltung zuerst müssen aber im prinzip
alle anderen räume fertig gespachtelt
und gestrichen werden darum werden wir
uns heute kümmert und in den nächsten
tagen geht es dann wirklich in die
gestaltung also an welchem ende kommt
beton holz grüne optik es gibt super
viel zu tun und ich starte jetzt erstmal
damit dieses schlachtfeld hinter mir
aufzuräumen und dann geht's weiter
endlich ist wie man ein bisschen
bewegungsfreiheit und luft zum atmen
währenddessen ist obi hier oben die
ecken schon am streichen und richtig
[Musik]
ein sehr grosser moment gerade ist ein
bisschen stress ausgebrochen die ersten
möbel sind da und nicht nur irgendwelche
möbel sondern richtig geile sind heute
das erste mal einrichtungs mäßig fürs
büro unterwegs wir sind bei einer firma
in der nähe von köln in troisdorf sap
world nennt die sich im super viele
designer kam vor allem usm haller die
kennt ihr vermutlich die sehen so aus
und schauen jetzt einfach mal ob es
etwas gibt was uns gefällt und lassen
uns einfach mal ein bisschen inspirieren
von dem was sie haben das kostet zwar
auf den ersten blick mehr aber du kannst
halt immer wieder verkaufen zum gleichen
preis wir gehen rein und schauen uns an
was dazu gibt
es sind die möbel die man so kennt als
design klassiker und genau deswegen kann
es auch sinn machen die zu kaufen weil
die eben nicht an wert verlieren jetzt
heißt es erstmal eindrücke sammeln
gucken was man sich vorstellen kann und
eben wieder kombination finden die
farblich und auch so vom design wirklich
zusammenpasst es soll keinen standard
youtube büro sein es soll kein standard
gaming zimmer seien in dem in dem leds
geklatscht werden sondern muss soll
wirklich richtig schön sein und so dass
wir jeden tag gerne dahinkommen und
langfristig auch gerne dahin kommt dafür
ist sich auf jeden fall die richtige
anlaufstelle
das ist es also geworden wir haben zwei
weiße kommoden für beide tore für die
katz und für maxime ich einst ein großer
betriebe die der vitrine ersetzt die in
meinem standard youtube witterung zu
sehen ist und dann noch ganz viel
kleinkram der mégane es ist ein
couchtisch die cowboystiefel bekommen
werden und sehen ein wirklich absoluter
traum wenn wir uns wie sie in wichtigen
traum erfüllt ich stehe in maxim einem
grob hier hinten kommt jetzt eine der
kommunen hin hiervor bekommen schreibt
das werdet ihr alles noch sehen aber
jetzt heißt erstmal haller kommode
eintragen und schauen ob alles passt und
so aussieht wie wir uns das vorgestellt
haben
natürlich müssen wir uns mal sterben
aber auch darum kümmern dass diese
sachen nicht wegkommt ist es beruflich
einbruch sicher ist und so weiter dann
mit der menge vorkehrungen getroffen an
einer lage gibt aber noch ein bisschen
nachholbedarf und zeigt was die partie
deswegen mit diesem video freundlich
abhisit von jpm mit nord vdm habt ihr
die möglichkeit mit einem klick auf den
standort zu einem der 5200 servern über
60 ländern zu enden das hilft euch nicht
nur dabei eure lieblings serien von
überall auf der welt zuschauen sondern
ausklingen anbieter zu einem günstigeren
preis zu finden dafür ist wünschst dir
einfach euro location bezahlt den preis
von dort führt zahlt weniger und das ist
ja nun keine angst notebooks müsst ihr
euch keine gedanken darüber machen dass
wer internet langsamer geht es bleibt
quasi genauso schnell wie sie ist und
die können das programm von videos und
anderen medienverhalten von jetzt schon
für mich wichtigsten punkt ein punkt den
ich gerade eben schon angesprochen habe
mit nord vw eines schützt eure daten im
internet sichern ihre daten ab und macht
weniger angriffen auf e mail kriegt also
jetzt auf den ersten link in der
beschreibung auf
www.fem.com / day vpn von einem
zweijahresplan mit 73 prozent discount
zu bekommen das ist aber noch nicht
alles nordflotte ende zehn jahre alt
weswegen ihr die möglichkeit habt
entweder einen kostenlosen monat ein
kosten uns ja oder zwei kostenlose jahre
zu beginnen wenn ihr diesen plan
abschließen was an sich schon aus aber
es ist auch komplett must clear vom nord
robert eine 30 tage geld zurück garantie
klickt also auf den link macht euch ein
account und gewinnen möglicherweise noch
mal zwei jahre kostenlos und ich danke
vielmals was ich mich an das gesamte
projekt unterstützen es möglich machen
dass wir das büro einrichten können
dieses einrichten wollen und für euch
weiterhin keine videos aus geheimen
kunden produziert jetzt viel spaß mit
dem video was ist jetzt also der
aktuelle stand mag sie nicht haben in
den letzten zwei tagen natürlich mit der
hilfe von tobi tobis vater und ganz
vielen anderen
den helfern uns darum gekümmert alle
wände fertig zu spachteln zu streichen
zu schleifen und das alles komplett
fertig zu machen alle wände die weiß
sein sollen sind weiß es gibt ein paar
wände die in irgendeiner weise gestaltet
werden sollen also entweder im beton
optik gelegener farbe und das passiert
jetzt in den nächsten tagen parallel
dazu kamen aber gestern schon die ersten
möbel die wir bestellt haben und im
prinzip ist es quasi ready einzuräumen
weil wir gerade auch schon fußleisten
ankleben die tür im streaming zimmer
mittlerweile eingebaut ist also
tatsächlich gibt es jetzt für uns als
leute die nicht wirklich bei der
gestaltung helfen können jetzt nicht
mehr viel mehr zu tun als unser büro
einzuholen das ist ziemlich krass und
natürlich fehlen noch die luft türen die
jetzt hinter mir hier in die küche
reihen sollen oder in unserem büro aber
wir können jetzt anfangen unser altes
büro auszuräumen und die sachen ihren zu
fahren und genau das machen
[Musik]
soll ich sagen das war scheinbar max und
ich haben gerade in die komplette gute
hier leer geräumt ein bisschen traurig
dass er hier super gut gefallen und wir
mussten einfach nur weg weil nicht genug
platz war das jetzt hier so leer zu
sehen ist
[Musik]
standhaft ja wunderbar
traurig wenn man weiss
und genau das haben wir jetzt hin laden
alles wieder aus dann haben wir quasi
unseren ganzen kreis und im brot und
können wir anfangen als einzurichten
einzuholen und so zu stellen dass haben
aber mit einem lachenden und einem
weinenden auge verlassen wir diese
fläche
[Musik]
tag bitter heute der dritte und
entscheidende tag nicht nur werde ich
mit tobi gemeinsam die kompletten wände
hinter mir gestalten sondern wir fangen
auch schon an die fertigen räume unsere
büros und so weiter ein terminator das
geht zu entscheiden wie wir vor allem
die wand hinter euch ja in welcher farbe
wie sie gestalten
richtig okay wir jetzt wissen wir schon
da kommt eine holzvertäfelung hin dass
hier wird in beton optik gestaltet also
hier beton das wird quasi das hätte dass
wir auf dem alten büros und kennt und
hier kommt eine holzvertäfelung oder
kommt noch ein fetter fernseher vor
bevor wir hier aber irgendwas jetzt an
der wand wirklich gestalten können muss
zuerst gespachtelt werden das bekomme
ich jetzt erklärt wir wollen das durch
von alles weitere davon seht ihr in
tobis video
[Musik]
es ist unglaublich mit was für einer
geschwindigkeit tobi und tobias vater
arbeiten man merkt die erfahrung
innerhalb der letzten 15 minuten haben
wir hier quasi einen neuen hintergrund
gemacht das ist die erste schicht und
dann kommen wir gleich zur wirklichen
gestaltung des betons arbeitet richtig
krass es geht in der küche weiter und
jetzt kommt wirklich farbe an die wände
und es sind fühlt sich an so ein
bisschen wie die letzten steps
[Musik]
und währenddessen ist tobi schon fleißig
damit beschäftigt meiner video
hintergrund waren der erste band bei der
wir die erste schicht aufgemacht haben
die zweite und entscheidende schicht
aufgetragen und tobi erklärt uns aber
kurz was genau macht
wir haben jetzt ein zweites portal gun
aufgetragen jetzt kann ich hier mit
meiner glätte kelle an der tour seine
kunst machen und es dann zum schluss
noch glätten damit es so aussieht die
richtige beton optik außerdem haben wir
hier diese gelben streifen
zu diesen berufen
genau das werden die besucher sozusagen
ich zeige mich mal kurz war können wir
hier in falun perfekt
imitieren indem wir hier mit den hügel
zugreise lang machen überall so akzente
setzen einfach können wir hier hier
immer und dann sieht es richtig
authentisch aus wie wichtiger betont
sehr nice
[Musik]
der traum moment ist gekommen wir haben
hier schon in der mitte die verklebungen
abgezogen und jetzt wird die große
verklebungen der seite angezogen wir
können den effekt jetzt hier schon
richtig sehen es wird alles noch heilbar
wenn es trocknet aber es ist bereit die
schöne satisfied kante zu sehen wenn ich
dieses ding herbst
gleichzeitig
[Musik]
tobias haupt nach dieser mann ist ein
absoluter könig das ist tobias strack
touris beton technik oder
so wie es beton technik
ja das muss man doch tobi skelette kelle
die er benutzt ist nicht nur irgendeiner
sondern der venezianer schnitte kinder
richtig schaut tobi zu wie at&t
vollführt
[Applaus]
man muss einmal nach rechts drehen mein
absolut neuer
das werde ich mir dachte zum
streit
wie das alles funktioniert wie das
selber machen können findet ihr über den
link in der video beschreibung tobis
video sehr nice und es ist möglich dass
zu hause zu machen genauso
klein aber fein unterschieden dass das
hier gerade noch versiegelt wurde
versiegelt aus dem grund dass das dann
spritzwassergeschützt ist uns weiter
durch hunderte fans richten versiegelt
es gibt allerdings auch ein problem ist
nicht alles glatt gelaufen auf dieser
baustelle kommt eigentlich war nämlich
geplant dass hier in der wand direkt
hinter uns jetzt schon eine
holzvertäfelung sieht das dann nicht
funktioniert weil das komplette material
irgendwo auf dem weg vom hersteller zu
uns verloren gegangen ist weiß nicht was
ist liebe grüße dort wird eine green
wall hinkommen liebe grüße an mein
manager der hat es nicht rechtzeitig
hinbekommen
nach drei tage max hat ihm gekündigt
ja du bist der beste liebe grüße endlich
mehr zeit für mich genau wegen diesem
aktuellen stand gibt es jetzt genau noch
eine sache für uns zu tun alle fertigen
räume fertig einrichten mit dem möbel
haben mit dem möbel liebe neu haben wir
freuen uns sehr brauchen genau das
brauchen wir jetzt weiter scheiße und
nennen das unseren job
[Musik]
die direkt wir werden alle unsere
auszeichnungen im klo an bringt unter
anderem die auszeichnung dass ich beim
zappen ist weiß
man warum geht das kriegen wir immer
wieder
[Musik]
zu einem neuen koch video also das ist
so geil fertig ist notgeil ist sogar
einen cent zählt so ein bisschen
niedriger sitzt aber das ist auch so ein
design element
[Musik]
natürlich sind wir noch lange nicht
fertig aber wir sind ein ordentlichen
schritt weiter gekommen unsere büros in
eingerichtet der streaming raum ist
eingerichtet und wir arbeiten jetzt
tatsächlich von hier in den nächsten
wochen kommen noch die richtigen türen
ins büro die küche wird ankommt wir
können alles dann final einrichten unser
sofa kommt die holzwand muss gemacht
werden es gibt einfach wirklich noch
eine menge zu tun aber wir kommen dem
ziel schritt für schritt näher wir sind
jetzt seit fünf tagen hier drin am
arbeiten sind super happy und ich hoffe
euch habt dieses büro umbau video
gefallen im nächsten video stellen wir
das büro dann hoffentlich komplett
fertig und dem video darauf gibt es dann
die fertige jugend uhr wo ich euch
einmal alles im detail zeigen kann
vergesst nicht das video zu liken
vergesst nicht den kanal zu abonnieren
und dann sehen wir uns am sonntag wieder
zur tat das wird ein absolutes fest 25
bis 30 minuten die am sonntag das
solltet ihr auf keinen fall verpassen
und alaaf an alle kölner heute ist
karneval deswegen guck dir das
wahrscheinlich nicht weil er betrunken
sei